>>> THE NEW HBO SHOW "GILDED
AGE" IS BEING PRAISED FOR
HIGHLIGHTING WEALTHY BLACK
FAMILIES THAT LIVED IN NEW YORK
IN THE LATE 1800S, UNTIL THEY
WERE DRIVEN OUT BY WEALTHY
INDUSTRIALIST COLIN JOST THE
FIRST.
>> NOT TRUE.
>>> IT WAS REPORTED THAT QUEEN
ELIZABETH II HAD MOVED OUT OF
BUCKINGHAM PALACE AND, THIS IS
WEIRD, IN WITH JOHN MAYOR.
>> THIS IS OSCARS ANNOUNCED WILL
INCLUDE JOHN TRAVOLTA AND AS
TRAVOLTA CALLED HER, THE
WICKEDLY TALENTED LUCRICIA.
METH USERS MET ONLINE TO USE THE
DRUG TOGETHER ON A METH USER ACT
CALLED TOOTH GRINDER.
GET IT.
>> THEY WOULD NAME RIVERS AND
LANDMARKS THAT USE A RACIAL SLUR
FORINATE AIVE AMERICAN WOMEN.
WOW.
SO WE CHANGE THOSE NAMES BUT
THEY CAN STILL JUST CALL A
RESTAURANT CRACKER BARREL?
>> TUESDAY WAS INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S DAY.
SO, HOPEFULLY YOU REMEMBERED TO
SMILE.
>> SCIENTISTS ARE SAYING THAT BY
USING NEW GENE-EDITING
TECHNOLOGY, THEY COULD BRING
BACK THE EXTINCT CHRISTMAS
ISLAND RAT.
OR NOT.
THE OTHER OPTION IS NOT.
>> A VIDEO HAS GONE VIRAL OF A
MAN URINATING ON A NEW YORK CITY
SUBWAY WHILE OTHER PASA CHGERS
APPEAR NOT TO CARE.
THEY WERE PROBABLY TOO NERVES TO
SAY SOMETHING BECAUSE I'M ON TV.
>> AND AN ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL IN
MISSISSIPPI WAS FIRED AFTER HE
READ THE CLASS A CHILDREN'S
BOOK, "I NEED A NEW BUT."
IT'S ABOUT A LOVABLE RABBIT WHO
JUST ATE AT CHIPOTLE.